okay now
pretty funny right like anytime
someone comes up to the board i don't
know if you feel the way i used to feel
when i was at school and it's kind of
like please don't scrutinize my answer
too much but actually that's when you
learn and taking on critical feedback
not that i think there's going to be too
much
today anyway it's one of the most
important skills you can develop not
just as a mathematician but like just as
a human being so let's have a look
together
top one here before we have a look at
this red line of working here
let's just have a look at what you've
been handed right part of what you're
doing here and all of these questions is
recognition it's one of the difference
between novices and experts a novice
looks at a question like where do i
begin with this right but an expert can
quickly recognize oh i recognize this
kind of problem i know what's the
appropriate tool and then i can use it
most efficiently
can someone tell me what kind of object
do we have here it's implied but i think
you mostly have worked it out i know you
know because you've done it working
someone else tell me
it's a product right and it's always
sneaky right that multiplication there
is is almost never written partly
because we have so many x's flying
around that look like multiplication so
is this the right application of the
appropriate rule
before we even look at whether it's the
right answer or not is it the right rule
to use right tool for the job it is
right this is uh how what's the order
we've done this in so this is u and v so
we've gone u v dash
v
u dash does that look like how it's
panned out
or did i swap them around that's like
u-v is that right
u dash v happier
the order doesn't matter as we've seen
because number one you're adding another
two you're multiplying both of which are
does anyone remember by the way it's
actually all the way back from five
years ago you learned the word starts
with a c that indicates operations that
can be changed in order to remember
has to do with if you were going for a
long drive to work
we call that commuting right you can
commute your different operations and
you get the same results so the
community of property
have a look at this what's actually done
from this line to this line can anyone
give me the
name for this
it starts with an f
this is yeah go ahead no one's given to
me this is factorization right so
noticing that
you could expand of course but there's
not much to gain given that you've got
this common factor of e to the x that
happens a whole lot when you're
differentiating because it remains
unchanged
and then from here to here
what's happening to this step
this is really important they actually
know what's going on that you can read
back working and understand what's the
difference yeah go ahead
it is a perfect square x squared i mean
the order that it's written in is a bit
funny because that just came from a
derivative but x squared plus two x plus
one sure enough
is x plus one all squared that's nice
isn't it are you happy looks okay
question two which i'm interested people
left till last
i don't know if you found it more
difficult but it's true like it's pretty
much one line of working again i'm going
to ask you that same question we use the
product rule here what's the appropriate
rule for a question like this
i mean it does look like something time
something but it's not is it what's
going on
come on you give it to me it's again
another word starts with c the language
is really important yeah this is chain
rule right so this is our inside
function in here that x squared plus 3x
if you call that f of x
when you use the chain rule on a
logarithmic function do you remember
it's this nice neat formula it's f dash
on
f that's what the derivative will look
like it's a bit small but i think we can
read it
three x squared plus three does that
look like f dash to you
thumbs up and then the denominator
remains unchanged logs and exponential
is really quite nice to deal with for
the most part okay
and then from there there's not much to
do is there there's not much unlike in
question one where there was lots of
nice neat factorization that would tidy
things up uh i think we all agree that
you're pretty much done at that point i
suppose you could pull out a three
and an x but you don't get a lot of
simplification off that anyway
all right let's have a look at this one
now
this is one of those interesting times
where you really genuinely can choose
multiple rules right what was the rule
that was chosen in this case
and it might have been different to
yours but i want to know what rule do
you see was used
this is protocol very good so you see
this has been phrased as something times
something and then you've got this in
index form so everything kind of matches
out
1 minus log x over x squared is where we
end up can i get some agreement or
yeah if you know it's fantastic okay now
would it have been simpler to go the
other path what's the other option you
could have done given how it's written
at the moment
good done quotient rule right call this
u call this v
you see you and you cannot avoid this
fraction right so ending up with v u
dash minus u v dash on v squared
might have got you marginally faster to
this x squared on the denominator and
the other bonus is
you can avoid negative indices i don't
like them because they make my brain
hurt but we got the right answer so it's
not like this is an illegitimate
approach
but just the more working you have the
more error prone it is just be watchful
okay last one up here um and i like that
there was um
a last minute course correction by the
student who was putting this answer off
so well done on realizing okay i need to
make some changes the first thing i'm
going to ask is and i i'm only asking it
now of all of you because i've signaled
it like two or three times and you're
probably like mr wu get over it right
this is why i'm not over it
forget about the derivative for a moment
here there's a minor issue of notation
that i think we can all do better that
we commonly make i've actually walked
around and i've seen literally everyone
in the room and do this at least once so
if you did this don't feel bad but i'm
still sitting here because i want us all
to do it better what's a minor piece of
notation that was missing off of the
working for this
question i'll let you have a chance to
redeem yourself go for it
yeah fantastic so this at this point
here
and you can see by this mountain of
working that results
something has changed right this is
actually the derivative not the original
function so please please please please
say this
it matters a lot
this is just like our very first
question product rule yeah does it look
like
this is u
this is v
have we done it right
what do you think so this is
u dash by the looks of it and this is v
does it check out
yeah it looks okay here comes this is v
dash and this is u
also looks like it checks out and then
there's this one over x that goes in
here and so it all kind of
neatly cancels when the unit is you're
happy with that is there any more you
could do to simplify off of here